move
so me that's that's more of a point to
why i think there's less wives
so i think traditionally and even
currently men
caught women we go out and we try to
find a woman
so if we can't find a woman i think
that's the problem now it's like we're
not we're not making it blunt enough
like
men don't want to get married to the
current women and we have multiple
reasons for that
like let's not talk about only fans
let's not talk about masculine women
like it's it's simple like we just don't
think women are good enough now for us
to settle down and marry
so do you think that women don't think
they're good enough for men or men don't
think they're good or do you think it's
um because i think that like women don't
think men are good enough for them even
if they're average
yeah that's the problem isn't it yeah
yeah i think because if you look in
history i don't
i think women dated and married average
guys historically because a lot a
question i ask on my show often is like
how much does your submission cost
and um and i say like to the point that
like if you said quit your job tomorrow
be with the kids you do it yeah i've
seen you ask them for the saturday and
they always say six figures even if
they're fives even though that's the
percent how much people how much men in
the world don't see yeah and so then the
next question is always are you top ten
percent girl and they say no and so it's
like you have girls that are not top ten
percent asking for a top ten percent
outcomes in order to submit i think the
word submit bothers women just the word
submit bothers them they don't dismiss
uh control to be honest i think they uh
i've heard this before someone i'm not
sure where but uh i heard that women
tend to think submission means slavery
like they think
what the month is
is just
absolutely final without reason you know
what i mean when submission really is
just um
you know it's not that you don't get a
say in the matter it's just that there's
a leader and you're a second in command
there's someone in primary command
but you're still in second in command
you have a lot of influence too it's
like because you can
i mean every every person knows like
that couple that's like really cute
we're like even even though the guy's in
charge like the woman's kind of in
charge because she's just so feminine
and kind of can get him to like see her
point of view you get there's a couple
that comes to your head right i said
okay i'm gonna give you an example it's
a little bit extreme but you actually
see the very clear
actually this will it's controversial if
you think about it but it's the
healthiest relationships
are from the bdsm
community and i will i will explain why
because i need you to define healthy
no no
i need you to like if so i'm going to
claim this the reason why i say it's
healthy is in order to
be
able to be in that type of relationship
because it is so extreme to the point
where sometimes there is a chance of
death yeah
because people engage in such extreme
activities
you need extreme trust in order to get
into it is there is there any data that
backs this up so the the idea no this
just sounds like this sounds crazy to me
so i i know i'm gonna give you the
example okay
because things are so extreme you're not
just going to do it even though it's a
fantasy you're not going to do it unless
you trust that person it's not going to
actually kill you does that make sense
so you have to discuss all the details
you you say what do i like what i don't
like they talk about what are the things
that you might
consider what are the things what is a
hard no what is a soft no what is and
after you've done all of that and you
agree that you're going to give it a try
you have to have a safe word
so
what happens in that relationship one
person's the dom
one person's a sub
who holds the power
the dom but is that just sexually though
what about house
no no no that's that's yes
that's that's that's a trick question
the ultimate power is the sub why
because they can determine when it stops
exactly
and that's the beauty of submission
ladies it's the beauty of
submitting because you know that you
trust that person so much that you
literally trust them with your life
and it's beautiful because you say to
this man i am willing to submit to you i
trust you ultimately for my livelihood
and my well-being ultimately i trust you
100
and i know that
if it because it is negotiable if i am
uncomfortable even slightly and i don't
i want to get out of it i want to step
away you have my back you will respect
me and you are going to give me that
ability to walk away and just just to
add to that um
i think when women hear submission they
just think like
the man's in front and they're just
behind like trodden along that i'm
telling you women that does not that's
not what submission means like and
there's certain points like i said
before that men actually like you to be
uh
in the forefront so like i said before
in a family you go to a family gathering
right we don't want to be putting out
plates for the kids and making sure
everyone's fed like that's that's when
you can dominate the situation it
doesn't mean we have to be head-hunched
all the time it just means
the majority of the time
we're your safety we're there for you to
protect you we're there to provide for
you so
it hasn't gotta be all the way like
where you're just trotted along a wheel
like in front of you there's gonna be
certain points where they dominate so um
i'm curious for you why do you think
there's a shortage of um
wives
i think
i don't i think they're uh jeopardizing
their chances to be wise but i think
there's a lot of potential husbands but
you could also make the argument there's
a shortage of both because they're being
turned off because
does that make sense because of the law
yeah yeah and so
yeah but i think
more women are jeopardizing their
potential to be wives but but i think
there's loads of potential husbands who
can actually get into the husband role
like they could be but it's just they
don't have the right girl to become that
exactly
what
what mistakes do you see girls make that
takes them out of the running to be
wives um
i don't know i just wanna
if i could just
simply say it well if they're
if they could easily get sucked into
things like feminism
like you know overall yeah i know people
say but there's this type of feminism
you know i think we could all agree that
all this like men are
trash and all that stuff
that's probably the biggest mistake if
you can if you can
allow that in
you know
in your mindset
and think that that's okay that's
probably the biggest one
that turns men off because you can even
just say that's that's enough because in
feminism they say you don't have to do
this he could just accept you the way
you are you don't have to do anything
you just have to exist and going back to
the actual topic of what we're talking
about
the bar is set very just ridiculously
high for men to the point where i i
i think that they deliberately do that
to take the piss
it's just so high it's unattainable
but for women i feel like there is no
but it doesn't even exist so you can see
that right there you see the girls on my
300 pound life with a man
is that monthly no i haven't even seen
that
i personally i personally think that the
problem these days in modern culture
whatever you want to call it
is that people is actually focusing on
the wrong things
so these girls are talking about and i
think there was recently these guys who
came in and said they're high value men
and
they wear flashy stuff they act you know
a certain way
and i can tell you that a high value
woman the ones that you actually the
good ones that you want as a wife
they're not going to say yes to that guy
because they're going to see him and be
like oh he's so insecure he needs to
drive a lambo in order to feel